our next speaker our first speaker this
afternoon is Rupert dar wall mr. dar
wall is a graduate of Cambridge
University where he studied economics in
history he worked as an investment
banker before becoming a special adviser
to the Chancellor of the Exchequer he is
currently a consulting director for the
White House writers group and a fellow
at the Center for Policy Studies
he has written extensively on both sides
of the Atlantic including for The Wall
Street Journal National Review of Forbes
The Financial Times The Daily Telegraph
and The Spectator
and he is the author most recently of
the book the age of global warming a
history and I'm happy to say and I think
the author would agree that it's not a
book Al Gore is going to endorse any
time anytime soon the title of his
presentation presentation today is
environmental scares yesterday and today
please welcome
Rupert Darwin
well it's it's very high honor for me to
be here with you and I have to say after
the the sheer quality of the speeches
the speakers you've had yesterday I am I
am Ali her see I have immense admiration
for what an amazing hero and then this
morning been Shapiro's extraordinary
extraordinary talk and Larry on on the
on the noble calling to teach and we'll
say the questions that come from the
floor of the interactions I've had with
you but I just come away thank you only
in America
can you get this
and what what what's B what what people
have been talking about I think in all
the all the presentations have been
about defending the values which
underpin Western civilization and these
are values that are not only worth
fighting for
they are values that must be fought for
by all of us I've been asked to talk to
you about environmentalism and the
politics of recurring environmental
scares of course the biggest and most
recent one being global warming and
there's a philosophical connection which
links the poison of political
correctness and the disease of
multiculturalism and the rise of
environmentalism environmentalism is an
ideology that represents a regression
from the standards set by the Scientific
Revolution at the end of towards the end
of the 17th century and a repudiation of
the values of the Enlightenment of the
18th century they reject tolerance and
the search for objectivity through
criticism and disagreement it is no
accident that the United States is
unique in having had a debate on global
warming
not just on what should be done about it
but more importantly public disagreement
about science behind it
even so fatwas have been pronounced by
the climate clara c against the so
called climate deniers scientists and a
United States Senator who have called
for anti-mafia racketeering laws to be
used against fossil fuel companies we
cannot take the continuance of freedom
of thought and speech for granted
nonetheless America's political culture
ultimately the American Constitution
which is I believe the single most
important product of the Age of
Enlightenment ensured debate discussion
and dissension and it's why hills dales
mission and values and principles are so
vital universities used to be the
repository of Enlightenment values but
those values are now dead or dying in
the
me and the First Amendment openly
scorned I will come to some of the
factors behind that in the context of
global warming and the rise of
environmentalism but in the outset would
like to mention one in particular the
corruption of the Academy by federal
research funding in his farewell address
President Eisenhower spoke of his dismay
at the extent of government funding of
scientific research a government
contract becomes virtually a substitute
for intellectual curiosity hi Eisenhower
warned the prospect of domination of the
nation's scholars by federal employment
project allocations and the power of
money is ever present and is gravely to
be regarded Eisenhower identified a
scientific technological elite who saw
themselves as purveyors of miracle cures
capturing government policy and he
cautioned against the recurrent
temptation of believing that some quote
spectacular and costly action might
offer a miraculous solution to all
current difficulties
thanks to environmentalism in our day
the miraculous cures have been inverted
that danger can be seen very clearly in
global warming now scientists discover
eco catastrophes and they preach
planetary apocalypses a key tenet of
environmentalism is the pre-eminent role
of science that science should be
mobilized to save the planet science as
global therapeutics this in turn gives
rise to another regressive feature of
global warming because climate science
became the leading branch of global
therapeutics it made climate science too
big to fail in becoming a tool of
political advocacy the nature of climate
science became antithetical to the
nature of science itself what is called
objectivity consists solely in the
critical approach the philosopher Karl
Popper rate because criticism risked
undermining the consensus needed to save
the planet evidence was with withheld
and criticism D legitimized the serving
the interests of maligned fossil fuel
corporations
and malevolent climate deniers climate
science is paying a steep price for its
political preeminence and perhaps the
most important idea I'd like to get get
across this afternoon is that
environmental environmentalism is an
ideology in just the same way as Marxism
is and can be analyzed as such but where
is Karl Marx and Friedrich Engels
themselves wrote the canonical text of
Marxism with environmentalism
there is no foundational text from which
the ideology sprang fully formed as it
were rather environmentalism is a
confluence of ideas into one big idea
which today has reached its highest form
in the idea of global warming
environmentalism borrowed the concept of
alienation from Marxism this time the
rich man's alienation from the means
that made him rich or in the case of
Prince Charles those that made that made
others rich Marxism was about changing
class relations with the means of
production of expropriating the
bourgeoisie you say the proletariat can
enjoy the full fruits of its labor by
contrast environmental environmentalism
requires a change in the means of
production themselves a far more radical
proposition requiring a rollback of the
Industrial Revolution and it's here that
there's a big divergence between the old
left Marxist and non Marxist and
environmentalism on the one hand Marx
and Engels saw capitalism in
industrialization as welcomed and
historically inevitable stages on the
road to communism they were therefore
anti-environment anti environmentalists
Marx and Engels utterly rejected the
notion of capitalist economies being
constrained by a fixed resource
endowment and by static technology quote
we start from the premise that the same
forces which have created modern
bourgeois society
we're also suffice to raise the
productive powers of each individual so
much he can produce enough for the
consumption of two three four five or
six individuals environmentalists on the
other hand
believe that modern industrial
industrial civilization has sundered
humanity's umbilical cord with nature in
a process that threatens our survival as
a species and the planets future too
many people consuming finite resources
upsetting fragile ecological balances
alarm about population growth was first
popularized by Thomas Malthus at the
beginning of the nineteenth century a
century in which Britain's population
nearly quadrupled and life expectancy
began its long-term increase despite the
total failure of Malthus is prediction
that population growth would be
repeatedly checked by famine disease and
war for true believers the idea that
there are all that there will be too
many humans on the face of the planet is
an article of faith
however malthus's ideas on human
population we're a major factor major
influence on Charles Darwin so in this
regard it's perhaps worth recalling what
Friedrich Engels wrote in the 1860s
because it has it has a big carryover to
environmentalists today noting
discredits modern bourgeois development
so much as the fact that is not yet
succeeded in getting beyond the economic
forms of the animal world to this day
think Paul Ehrlich in his bestseller the
Population Bomb Barlett biologists are
among the leading anti population
preachers by the middle decades of the
20th century has been Shapiro and we had
a question from the floor we talked
about the the Frankfurt School and
Marxist had to work out why the
bourgeoisie why the working-class and
advanced capitalist societies showed no
inclination at all to revolution that
the Frankfurt School who has been said
they came from that they came from they
fled Nazi Germany and settled in in in
America for a short time for 20 years
some of them merged Marx with Freud to
develop a cultural explanation but doing
so led to a break between the old left
and the new left intellectuals such as
Herbert Marcuse castigated American
blue-collar workers
as accomplices in the emergence of
fascism in late-stage capitalist society
quote violation of the earth is a vital
aspect of the counter-revolution mark
Uzi told a 1972 conference on ecology
and revolution he act together protests
against the Vietnam War
with environmentalism the genocide 'el
war against people is also ecocide their
training in Marxist dialectics enabled
the Frankfurt School to furnish
progressives with the linguistic
weaponry to fight the culture wars with
which we'd become so familiar they
perfected the technique of taking two
words with antithetical meanings and
ramming them together to drain them of
all positive attributes totalitarian
democracy is one repressive tolerance
the title of a polemic mark who wrote in
1965 is another in this way the New Left
jettisoned the old left's promotion of
industrialization and the economic
interests of the working class for
anyone who is not a Republican operative
it is plain to see that the crisis on
the Left caused by its abandonment of
the interests of working people in favor
of saving the planet presents a huge
opportunity for right-of-center
politicians
markku from the Frankfurt School have
had a great impact on American
university life out of all proportion to
their number and I think in leeching out
the values of the Enlightenment from
American universities in the words of a
historian of the Frankfurt School who's
very sympathetic to them quote although
they wrote and lectured about an
intellectual tradition critical of most
aspects of US society scholars of the
Frankfurt School invited into the
establishment earning chairs at such
prestigious universities as Harvard Yale
Princeton Cornell Columbia Duke the you
know University of California at
Berkeley and the University of Chicago
other developments around this time
reinforced the Frankfurt schools call
for a radical rejection of Western
industrial civilization and Western
values the sudden emergence of
environmentalism as a political movement
could be dated with precision 1962 and
publication of Rachel Carson's Silent
Spring
in reality Silent Spring is a work of
fiction and all the more powerful for
that its impact was immense I would go
so far as to say that Silent Spring is
the most consequential book of the
post-war era just ten years separate its
publication from the first major UN
conference on the environment in
Stockholm in 1972 the nature and purpose
of the Natural Sciences also began to
change around this time it was in the
1960s in the early 1970s that scientists
staked a claim to political power when
the West experienced its first
environmental wav'd which have been was
propelled by Silent Spring 1968 saw the
formation of the Union of Concerned
Scientists ninety-eight thousand strong
nowadays with a twenty eight million
dollar campaigning budget its website
proclaims its mission as being about the
health of the planet in the early 1970s
scientists claimed the economic growth
was in conflict with nature and
environment in 1972 37 eminent experts
including five Fellows of the Royal
Society and 16 holders of science chairs
at British universities put their names
to a document that predicted the
termination of industrial civilization
within the lifetime of people then
living from the 1960s onwards for the
belief that man's mankind's
interventions in nature risk
catastrophes of one kind or another led
to a recurrence of environmental scares
and I use the word scare advisedly
advisedly because that's exactly what
they were the first spurt sparked by
Carson and Silent Spring was the
pesticide scare in particular DDT it led
the Nixon administration to announce the
EPA's banning of DDT on the eve of that
first UN conference it's in Stockholm
Nixon's DDT ban was pure politics
what else would you've expected just
like Barack Obama's announcement
blocking Keystone XL in the run-up to
the Paris climate summit two months ago
indeed Paris 2015 is the direct
descendant of Stockholm 1972
being the 21st Conference of the parties
of the UN Framework Convention on
Climate Change which was signed in 1992
Rio Earth Summit which had been convened
to mark the 20th anniversary of the
Stockholm conference so there you have a
history of the climate change
conferences in just one centers that
that that Stockholm conference stands at
the confluence of two vast tributaries
the environmentalism of the North met
the development agenda of the south the
pivotal figures in bringing this about
was the conference organizer the
Canadian more a strong and the Britain
Barbara Ward
Barbara Ward was the most Network person
on the planet before the Internet she
knew everyone presidents prime ministers
Pope's and third world leaders during
the 1945 British general election she
escorted a young named American naval
officer John F Kennedy Lyndon Johnson
said that hers were the only books he
read writing to her two days before he
left the White House whatever mark we
made in these last five years clearly
bears your stamp - to avert the threat
of a third world boycott of the UN
conference Barbara Ward and Morris
strong sipping Dom Perignon in his New
York apartment they were very upmarket
champagne socialists devised a political
formula to insulate the third world's
development aspirations from first world
environmentalism the essence of what
they came up with is that economic
growth is double-edged in the case of
rich countries growth harms environment
in the case of developing nations growth
improves the environment after stock
came Barbara Ward fleshed out the terms
of the alliance between environmentalism
and the third world and the third world
which today the world knows as
sustainable development the price of
getting third world countries to the
table was the promise of massive
resource transfers from north to south
this agenda became part of the UN
sponsored new international economic
order on sisters systems of governance
for the so called global Commons in the
1970s in the 1980s they were it was it
was the oceans
now it's the atmosphere and some form of
global taxation to reflect the North's
exploitation of the South's resources
its ideology was deeply hostile to
capitalism the Declaration of the
establishment of the new international
economic economic order portrays
unregulated businesses as predatory and
destructive Ronald Reagan and Margaret
Thatcher fought against that among the
demands of the the Eckener international
economic order in the early 1980s and
for some time it looked like it had
disappeared but it never really went
away it reappeared in new and green garb
in 1992 of the Rio Earth Summit
Conference organizer Morris strong the
Order annuit international economic
order is a clue to something else it
will come as no surprise to you that
Ward was a great believer in government
planning indeed planning on a planetary
scale it was imperative for mankind to
know where it's going and what the world
would look like in 20 years time wrote
Ward wrote in a 1966 paper spaceship
earth quote it is surely inconceivable
that we should turn the whole human
experiment over to forces of change
which we can neither master nor even
fully understand
thus massive resource transfers Hillary
Clinton of the 2009 Copenhagen climate
conference was promising 100 billion
dollars a year and if not global
government government then global
governance have formed part of the core
of environmentalism for over four
decades as you can see environmentalism
is a lot more than the environment and
in some respects it's not about the
environment at all and here it's time to
dispel a common myth about
environmentalism that it is about
conserving nature and preserving
endangered species in fact
environmentalists concern about nature
is highly partial it all depends on the
cause not the effect one reason
environmentalist can campaign against
DDT was because it allegedly led to
thinner eggshells
of eagles and other Raptors putting
their survival at risk we now know this
was false
Raptor egg shells have been thinning
long before the introduction of DDT on
the other hand environmentalists don't
object when Raptors are killed in
environmentally friendly ways Eagles and
other birds of prey are attracted to
thermals you get in the Hill Country
those same Hill sites are now attracted
are now dotted with wind turbines so
which should it be Raptors or wind farms
for environmentalists the mass eco
slaughter week of eagles raptors and
migratory birds by the rotating blades
of wind turbines is necessary wind farms
good coal-fired power stations bad the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change the IPCC even has a set of holy
spirits numbers to justify this wind
powered avian Holocaust as I said the
determining factor is the cause not the
effect after DDT next down the pipe was
the acid rain scare of the 1970s and
1980s and in many ways this is the most
interesting as it is a as it really was
a dry run for global warming they had
the same enemy coal-fired power stations
and they had the same answer emissions
cuts sulfur dioxide for one carbon
dioxide for the other the National
Academy of Sciences linked there to the
science of acid rain it said was much
further developed than global warming
what the na s doesn't want you to know
is how the supposedly subtle science of
acid rain subsequently fell apart
sure past stations make rain more acidic
rain is naturally acidic especially
after thunderstorms but acid rain wasn't
the cause of lake acidification acid
rain wasn't destroying forests a handful
of brave scientists found that changes
in land use not acid rain had caused the
lakes of the Adirondacks to become
acidic and lose their game fish the EPA
knew all this full well when it pushed
the clean air of
amendments through Congress in 1990 and
delayed publication of the final report
of the ten-year federal acid rain
research program which set this all out
yet 25 years on if you go to the EPA's
website it falsely states that acid rain
is a serious environmental problem
affecting large parts of the United
States that is particularly damaging to
lakes streams and forests how to say
this politely what the EPA asserts about
acid rain is a downright scientific
fraud given this does anyone really
think that the EPA is in the business of
discovering the truth about global
warming and would it tell us if it found
in it anything that might put a question
mark over what has become politically
settled science so it's perhaps worth
going back to what climate scientists
are saying about global warming before
politics settled the science the first
chairman of the IPCC burt berlin
acknowledged that manmade global warming
was not something which you can prove
the IPCC's first assessment report
produced in 1990 is distinctly equivocal
it noted that a large that a global
warming of a larger size had almost
certainly occurred at least once since
the end of the last glaciation without
any appreciable increase in greenhouse
gases quote because we do not understand
the reason for these past warming events
it is not yet possible to attribute a
specific proportion of the recent
smaller warming to an increase in
greenhouse gases the IPCC went on to
note the existence of many significant
uncertainties and inadequacies in the
observational climate record in
knowledge of the causes of natural
climatic variability and computer models
for this reason the IPCC concluded that
quote scientists working in this field
cannot at this point in time make the
definitive statement yes we have now
seen an enhanced greenhouse effect
unquote
in climate activists parlance in 1990
the IPCC were climate deniers so
whenever you hear Bill McKibben or
senator Sheldon Whitehouse or the
Attorney General of New York or Bernie
Sanders and Hillary Clinton claim that
Exxon Mobil whoever somehow hid the
truth about global warming point them to
what the IPCC IPCC was saying in 1990
and then asked have have there been any
scientific discoveries since 1990 to
justify changing that conclusion sure we
have had the now discredited in hockey
stick which purportedly showed falling
tech bubble temperature for nine hundred
years in a sudden increase of the start
of the 20th century we've had satellite
data of atmospheric temperature which
the climate clarity prefers to downplay
and we've had 18 years or so of climate
model predictions bounding ahead of
observations that should give Santa any
true scientist pause for thought a good
model is a means of systematically
bringing together understanding of a
scientific problem to yield predictions
and then test that understanding against
nature if the predictions are wrong it
follows there's something wrong or
incomplete with scientists understanding
I referred a little earlier to a
profound and subtle change in the nature
and purpose of science and here's a key
point about it this is not about
advancing scientific knowledge on
climate it's about war and science is
one of the weapons used in that war
science has been weaponized the climate
wars will decide whether we let the
market provide us with the cheapest most
reliable forms of energy to power
economic progress take away fracking and
the anemic economy of the art Obama
years would now have barely recovered or
it will determine whether America will
fall follows Europe down its wind and
solar policy calamity right at the
moment that President Obama and the EPA
are taking America down the path of
energy purgatory
the Europeans are waking up to the
enormity of their mistake two years ago
the European Commission published a
paper on its post-2020 climate and
energy target targets it gave Europe had
get out of jail card the new renewable
and decarbonisation targets would only
apply to Europe as a whole there would
be no targets for individual member
states imagine if the EPA had said a
federal target but no state targets the
clean power plan would be dead
even if the consensus on global warming
turns out to be correct one country
cutting their greenhouse gases gas
emissions only makes sense if everyone
else does it without the prospect of
that happening the rationale goes up in
smoke
thus the real purpose of the Paris
climate agreement is to justify the
ruinously expensive renewable energy
programs beloved by environmentalists we
saw this happening with the Obama
administration arguing before the
Supreme Court the implementation of the
clean power plan was essential to
meeting the commitments the US had just
made in the Paris climate agreement in
its five-to-four decision on Tuesday the
court froze implementations between
power plan pending the outcome of legal
challenges but it's worth recalling as
Ben Shapiro mentioned with his reference
to Justice Kennedy Justice Kennedy is
the swing vote and whatever swings that
vote Ben knows of the outcome of the
entire legal challenge to the clean
power plan I don't like to think what
the feature of the United States hangs
on if that's the case but something else
is going on underneath all this
something that President Eisenhower
foresaw over 50 years ago speaking at
the 2007 barly climate conference former
Vice President Al Gore told climate
delegates that they should feel
privileged quote to be alive at the
moment at a moment when a relatively
small group of people could control the
destiny of all generations to come so we
come to the bottom line
global warming involves the oldest
question in politics who governs an open
society philosopher Karl Popper wrote is
one that not merely tolerates dissenting
opinion but respects them democracy that
is a form of government devoted the
protection of the open society cannot
flourish if science becomes the
exclusive possession they closed set of
specialists in the 1620s Francis Bacon a
former law chance of England argue that
the Republic should be governed by
scientists the generation after bacon
John Locke's political philosophy is
based on the Socratic insight that to
err is human one that is applicable to
science and politics alike the
Constitution of the United States is the
fullest and most perfect embodiment of
Locke's political philosophy here we
have popular sovereignty mediated by a
constitutional order of checks and
balances it was during the age of global
warming that the west came closest to
realizing Bacon's vision the outcome of
the climate Wars was not decided in
Paris in December it will not be decided
in Beijing by the Communist Party of
China the outcome of this war will be
decided later this year on November the
8th and it will be decided by you thank
you
we have some time for some questions
please raise your hand
yes isn't environmentalism and being is
in a matter of a balance and being
sensible about it
in other words isn't part of the problem
going to such an extreme you're not
going to say it's a bad thing to improve
the air quality in Los Angeles for
example with emission standards as
opposed to Beijing or they you know the
you can't even see the Sun or the the
polluted water and streams so I mean we
need some sensible you know controls and
and and government efforts but so isn't
it isn't it basically a matter of degree
and using just some common sense so I
completely agree with you what you the
two words that stick out that's is
sensible and common-sense I'll take a
I'll take an example of another
disastrous European policy which is
nearly 50% in some countries of new cars
in in some European countries have
diesel engines and this was and this was
to increase fuel economy so more mpg
means less carbon dioxide coming out of
the car emission cop car tailpipe but
the consequence of that is you have more
Maturin oxides and you have more
particulates and so the air quality of
European cities is now converging is it
it was declining and it's know now
deteriorating and it's converging with
third world cities so environmentalism
all the monomania about carbon dioxide
and decarbonization is leading to this
perverse outcome of worsening the the
environment and that's where it that's
where Ajay that's why I'd mentioned
about windmills and wind turbines and
and the effect on bird life if it really
was about preserving nature and and so
forth you wouldn't be doing wind farms
period
thank you very much in a society that
has a knee-jerk reaction I'm interested
in and not what you would say if you had
your crystal ball what you think the
fallout will be as a result of Flint
Michigan's water crisis well I would
take I would take a another example of
environmental mishandling which is the
EPA releasing was it 2 or 3 million tons
of of mine wastewater in that River in
Colorado and the problem is that when
you're saving the planet you're not
doing the things that really matter
you're not looking after the local
pollution most pollution is local and
you need to focus on that on the local
local pollution is when when they get
into saving the planet that you lose
touch with all that thank you for coming
out today if I understood you correctly
you said that there were one or more
voices in Europe that are starting to
see the light and to speak out in terms
of this topic other than yourself are
there is there anyone on the horizon in
Europe who has a chance of being heard
on the world stage and inject what some
of us would call some sanity into this
discussion I think it's slightly I think
the sanity has come come from reality
you know reality is the great educator
and the reality is that Europe's
renewable energy program has proved
disastrous is created you've got very
high electricity prices Germany and
Denmark have have to the the highest
electricity prices in the world it shuts
down it destroys the economics of gas
and coal-fired power stations and so
they've got this immense practical
problem and they don't know what to do
about it but the first reaction of the
of the European Commission would say
well hold on guys we just we don't want
to keep keep going on down this route so
if you like you know I'd love to claim
credit for for making the
European Commission see sense but
actually that isn't the case what is
what has happened it's just reality the
reality is so horrible you can't ignore
it anymore and that will happen here but
you don't want to go there you don't
want to get to the gruesome reality
where you have to say we actually have
to back off out of this you want to look
what's happening in Europe and learn
from it and that's the one thing the
Obama administration the EPA do not have
a clue about how can we get your message
to the right people in America well
first of all I think one of the the
things the key key thing is not to be
intimidated by the campaign of D
legitimization to get an T and to speak
at that is first and the first and
foremost because part of what this what
the other side of you like you're doing
is trying to silence criticism so the
first thing is to get people talking
about it the second thing is that as I
mentioned right at the outset the United
States is the only country where there
has been a debate in a political debate
about global warming and Republicans
have disagree a lot of Republicans
disagree with Democrats and the global
warming consensus so there's a clear you
know you have a debt you have much more
of a Democratic choice than anywhere in
the world because in Europe but every
political parties signed up to this
every party with a hope of governing so
you have no choice here you have a
choice and that's why I said November
8th is decision time
I have two questions already first of
all is there a way to hold Gina McCarthy
up to sufficient ridicule so that she
has to resign whether Obama has her back
or not
and the second question is is there
anybody out there calling windmills what
they are which is an uglification of our
landscape and a killer of six hundred
thousand or however many bird six
hundred thousand birds per year the
problem with the EPA is that it's a
completely unaccountable federal agency
and it really the only person Gina
McCarthy is accountable to is the
President and that's why that's why I
come back to the answer I just gave it
really depends on the outcome of the
next election I completely agree with
you on if you look at the way what the
EPA I've got an article into on today's
National Review Online about this but
the EPA's is a lawless agency it goes it
doesn't just go to the limits of the law
it goes way beyond way beyond the law
and you've seen this it's been it's been
involved in the in in covert lobbying
which the General Accounting Office said
was violated federal federal law so as I
say this is this is an this is a an
agency that that's out of control but
it's on our it's not answerable to
anyone other than the president so what
was the second question so I think with
what what you see with the a what I call
the avian Holocaust is that a lot of the
environmental NGOs are a lot of their
funding comes from very large West Coast
foundations that are very very green and
they are they are very closely aligned
with the with the Renewable industry and
that is a big problem on the other hand
there are smaller nature nature
conservation societies which have
the the interests of the birds first and
foremost but I think this this is this
is a crisis of environmentalism is
environmentalism about protecting nature
or is it about a huge political agenda
and I think because the
environmentalists NGOs have gone on on
on the ideological agenda it is leading
to all these problems and at some point
they will be called out on it 10 years
ago the term global warming was somewhat
surplice i'ma change in a second part of
the question as far as that first part
is just fine
I have a I prefer to talk about global
warming because that's the title of my
book there is there is it is this is a
difficult one because if you look at the
nomenclature there was talk about
climate change the climate change we can
date it quite we know that they were
talking about climate change in 1988
because the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change that's when it was
established I think partly that why they
talked about climate change because as
some of some of you been saying to me
recall it in the in the early 70s the
concern then was cooling so in a way you
can talk about climate change kind of
wraps up all the threats to the you know
that temperatures might be a low they
might go higher call it climate change
so I think it I think that's that's the
reason why the IPCC adopted that and
Ament no mental Joan if you look at the
when the IPCC was formed before its
formation which happened there build-up
there was through that through the late
80s and the mid 80s the the people then
would have been aware of that actually
they've been 10 years before they've
been talking about the threat of global
cooling so you choose a name that covers
both that comes to me about eight years
ago we went to the Heartland Institute
conference on global warming and there
were 88 PhDs along with the president of
the Czech Republic who wrote the book
blue planet in green shackles and he
explains the political nature of it but
dr. Lenz in from MIT dr. soon from he's
with Smithsonian Institute of
climatology dr. art Robinson I went with
an open mind there were 88 PhDs and the
president of the Czech Republic and they
all said that there's no scientific
evidence that what we're doing is
affecting the co2 or causing global
warming they spent over a hundred
thousand dollars to try to get any news
agency to come there and the only news
agency that would come or these obscure
little ones in Europe but I mean it and
dr. Robinson and dr. Soong
they submitted their research and had
26,000 scientists say that global
warming doesn't exist but nobody ever
hears about any of these things and I
just wanted you to comment on that yeah
I think this is this is what I referred
to earlier is that is the D
legitimization of criticism and
alternative views and it's it's part of
its it's a huge you've got they've got a
take competing explanations off the
table and that's why it's terribly
important as I said earlier is to keep
talking about it and even though that
conference wasn't reported it will have
some impact things ripple out and I
can't can't save more you know clearly
it's critical to keep talking about it
and present alternative points of view
yeah environmentalism is is very
interesting because the touched on my
talk I said this is my ideology compare
it to Marxism I think the thing about
environmentalism as I call it its ethics
for the wealthy if you show that if you
show the world I care about saving the
planet
yeah in a yak you gain immunity from
from criticism from from the left about
having too much money and that's I think
that accounts for a lot of why why a lot
of wealthy people are so ostensibly
about being green it's as I say ethics
for the wealthy
that's terrific what's your position on
nuclear power this is a source that's
couldn't be cleaner and I personally
need to be terribly mismanaged by the
federal government as well as industry
nuclear power is once you've got a
nuclear past it once you've built a
nuclear power station the economics are
very very clear you want to keep that
nuclear power station running for as
long as you possibly can because the
costs are upfront in terms of building
it and then the costs of their costs at
the end when you decommission it that's
where the costs are and the running cost
in the middle are really are really
quite low
and that's what's very interesting
what's happened in Germany why Germany
which has been the leader in the
greening of Europe you look what's
happening in Germany after Fukushima
Angela Merkel panicked and she's ordered
the rapid closed down of the German
nuclear industry if Merkel and the
Germans really concerned about co2
emissions you wouldn't do that you keep
those nuclear power stations going on
for as long as possible
so what Germany shows is this isn't
really about global warming they say
it's about global warming but if it was
really about global warming you wouldn't
shut down a single nuclear power station
well so far I wouldn't want to suggest
which it's where you who do you where
you vote it's sort of kind of but I
would I'm gonna post that there are some
things you can hear with some
politicians you just know they're gonna
be really bad on this so when when Jeb
Bush says I want to I want to create
consensus in Washington and there are so
many people on the planet we're bound to
be having an effect on climate kind of
alarm bells ring a little bit you know
I came from Iceland and they have about
the cleanest environment in the world in
Iceland the electricity is is produced
by geothermal and hydroelectric the
houses are heated geothermal yeah we had
a little volcano in Iceland last year
seven months and we were the biggest
polluter
six of the seven months in the world
country of three hundred and thirty
thousand people well I think I think I
think the country that actually takes
I've already said I think I think
Germany schools very highly as a as a
climate hypocrite for closing down its
nuclear power power stations but the
other one that's you know it's strongly
in the running I wouldn't put Iceland
there now I've been twice and once I
really love the country but I think the
one that the other one that sticks out
is Norway you know they're going zero
they they're boasting they're going zero
carbon and where's their wealth come
from it comes from under the North Sea
was from oil I mean you could just come
and make that stuff up can you
that's a good question I think it must
have been the the question is Barbara
Ward when was Barbara Ward put in the
House of Lords and my guess is it would
have been a Labour government in the mid
19th century died I think it was in 1981
and so my guess but I'd have looked that
up she was should have been put in the
house of laws
I mean she's it's very interesting when
she died if you read The Guardian a bit
tree it didn't make any reference to her
her extraordinary impact on the
environmental debate and the New York
Times called her I think they called her
something like a they described as a
propagandist but really she was a much
more important and pivotal figure than
that in in the creation of the modern
environmental movement thank you very
much for having the courage to speak out
as you do scientists that are skeptical
including very famous ones
Richard Lyndon of MIT Ian Plummer of
Australia even Bjorn Lomborg who agrees
with some of the global warming ideas
are ostracized and have funding removed
and their positions at the research
institutions compromised
have you seen any backlash against your
position since you're outspoken and what
would you say to those scientists that
are bold enough to speak out despite the
fact that their personal positions are
often compromised as a result of doing
so
what what you've described is what what
President Eisenhower warned about in
that in his in his farewell speech and
if you look at what happened with acid
rain it's very instructive because the
scientist who the lead scientist on the
federal program research program was he
had the EPA demonize him and they they
got together a some tame scientists to
do a phony peer review of his work and
said what what the scientist has
produced is absolute trash he's
worthless he doesn't know anything he's
he's talking about and it got so bad
this scientists threatened to sue the
deputy administrator of the EPA and then
the EPA did this he got in a bit of
panic about it and they FedExed
an apology to this scientist but he got
the apology but he didn't get any
further research work so I I'm afraid I
don't have any good news on that school
I think the power of politics in the
state and the climate industrial complex
is so strong that it's extremely
difficult for scientist bassy they are
taking a decision to sacrifice their
career when they speak out which is why
it's it's older scientists who've
nearing the end of their working lives
who are in the position to speak out but
I think that aspect is that is the price
that science has paid for
environmentalism and global warming
how about yourself have you experienced
any backlash on being an outspoken
critic yeah I've had someone to
interesting reviews of the book I mean I
was in the Sunday Times guy review
compared me to having the jaws of a
hyena stuff like that but you know that
kind of thing I can I can live with
thank you I've heard that in terms of
global warming that water vapor is the
major contributor and with carbon
dioxide representing 400 parts per
million of the error it's actually a
minor contributor and it's actually good
for plants if it were to increase any
trees well it's it's certainly true that
more carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
increases plant growth it's also the
case that the most ubiquitous and
strongest greenhouse gas is as you say
water vapor and my understanding of
assad's is that the IPCC's the consensus
view or predictions of warming depend on
more co2 causing more water vapor so
it's the amplification effect of of co2
of co2 on on water vapor that's the V is
critical to the values they get for
global warming but this all has to be
proved and the only proof is in
observations matching your predictions
against observations and every year that
passes the gap between prediction and
observation has widened and that you
know if they've been if they were true
scientists they'd be asking ourselves
well actually we have to revise our we
have to revise you know perhaps there
isn't so
of an amplification effect but that is a
matter for scientists scientists to work
out not to justify their predictions but
to change to accept that they need to
change their understanding of what's
going on in the Earth's atmosphere thank
you thank you very much